[MUSIC]
My name is Yangbing Li.
I'm a Senior Vice President and
General Manager at VMware.
I lead what we call the storied and
the availability business unit here.
So in the beginning of 2014,
I was making a career
transition moving from China back
to Palo Alto, our headquarters.
Our head of talent development and
HR suggested
that I consider SEP to open up my horizon,
expand my thinking about what's
possible out there, build new networks.
I went into SEP trying to expand my
understanding of business leadership.
I've been in a technical leadership
role for many, many years.
So I was very interested in thinking
about how do I expand my horizon
from technology to business leadership?
Within a year coming back from SEP,
I was given the opportunity to change
from VP of engineering role to a GM role,
essentially leading up and
coming business that we have in storage.
Reflecting on what I learned in SEP,
one thing that really opened my eyes was
there's just so much beyond technology and
engineering in product.
When you run a business, so
how do you maintain a focus
of creating a sense of
innovation incubation for
new development areas and
new revenue stream?
But in the meantime, continue to
support and grow existing businesses
constantly a leadership struggle but
in the innovator's dilemma.
I constantly draw to my SEP language for
ideas and inspirations.
SEP gave me a lot of good framework,
lots of powerful languages to let me
think about the business problems
that I face today or ongoing basis.
In the past few years we've been
on this what we initially consider
impossible goal of a building a billion
dollar business here in my team.
And we just celebrated that milestone.
SEP, I really see it as a great catalyst
in the evolutions of myself as a leader.